[Music]
could there be an even better planet for
us than
earth scientists are searching for a
super habitable world that wouldn't just
rival Earth but be a place where life
could Thrive even more easily and
they're looking at
exoplanets how would we discover earth
Earth
2.0 what would make an exoplanet
habitable and how long would it take to
get
there this is what if and here's what
would happen if we discovered Earth
2.0 you wouldn't be able to find an
exoplanet by looking through a telescope
all you'd see is the bright glare of the
Stars they orbit NASA built the Kepler
Telescope to discover exoplanets and
before it ran out of fuel the Kepler
Telescope surveyed our region of the
Milky Way galaxy its technology uses the
transit method to find planets hundreds
of light years away how it measured the
fluctuation of light coming from distant
Stars when a planet transits or passes
in front of a star the star isn't as
bright so the Kepler telescope uses that
to detect
exoplanets this is not an easy thing to
do but during its 9-year lifetime the
Kepler Telescope confirmed the existence
of
4,367
exoplanets could any of them be Earth
2.0 hey just by virtue of the fact
you're watching this we know you love to
learn just like us I really wanted to
take my learning up a notch this year so
I figured I'd learn a new new language
I've got a lot of German in my family so
I wanted to give German a shot that's
why I've been using the sponsor of
today's video Babble to help me out it's
not only a fun challenge but it'll help
me connect better with my family members
Babble is one of the top language
learning apps in the world it's
scientifically proven to help you start
speaking a language in just 3 weeks and
it's not all about Theory they use
lessons to help you have practical
conversations in the real world check
out how I've been using it this is what
if have you ever wanted to learn a new
language well with Babel you can speak
with confidence and have real world
conversations it's got expert crafted
lessons Games Live classes even podcasts
it's already helped me reach my 2024
goal of learning more and exploring a
new language so why don't you give Babel
a shot and get 60% off your subscription
Link in the description below if you're
a longtime fan of what if you've
probably heard this before but Earth is
a very special place and even if a
planet is deemed to be habitable it
doesn't mean that it resembles Earth
very much a habitable planet is a rocky
planet located in the habitable zone
allowing water to stay on the planet's
surface in its liquid form that's it
Venus and Mars are habitable planets but
they are definitely not like Earth so
let's talk about three major conditions
that we'd look for when searching for an
even better version of
Earth First it would need to have
sunlight our Sun's lifespan is about 10
billion years and it took 4 billion
years for anything more complex than the
simplest life form to pop up on our
planet but k type dwarf stars have
lifespans of about 70 billion years so
if we found an exoplanet orbiting a k
type star there would be more time for
life to evolve and live on it the second
major condition is temperature a planet
that's too hot or too cold wouldn't be
able to host the life forms we'd need to
survive but if we find a Planet that's a
mere 5° warmer than Earth and it has
more water we could be looking at Earth
2.0 covered in a lush biodiverse
rainforest the third major condition
we'd be looking for is
size gravity retains a planet's
atmosphere and there's a direct
relationship between gravity and a
planet's size so if we find a Planet
that's only 1 and 1/2 times larger than
Earth it would be able to hold on to its
interior heat and maintain its
atmosphere for a longer
time but bigger isn't always better
while earth-sized exoplanets are usually
Rocky about 50% of the exoplanets larger
than Earth are gas giants and if an
exoplanet is too small it would likely
be Barren like Mars so are there any
exoplanets out there that meet these
requirements
okay I found a planet that could be
super habitable Kepler
1649c could be a contender to become
Earth
2.0 it's 300 light years away and orbits
a red dwarf star it gets sunlight but
only 75% as much as Earth so it might be
a bit cooler there and there wouldn't be
any seasons on Kepler
1649c a full orbit only takes 19 and 1/2
Earth days so we'd need to get used to
that oh and it could be tidy locked
which means one side of the planet
constantly faces its sun while the other
side faces
space Also living on a planet that
orbits a red dwarf star could be
risky sometimes red dwarf stars send out
massive flares dousing an orbiting
planet in UV light and creating huge
temperature
fluctuations but if we decide that
Kepler
1649c is worthy of becoming Earth 2.0
what would happen
next well using our current technology
it would take at least 2,000 years to
reach this Earth 2.0 and since this
planet is so far away we only know about
its size the distance to its star and
the makeup of its atmosph osphere so we
could pack up humanity take the
multi-generational trip to Earth 2.0 and
discover that it's more like a Neptune
2.0 uh yeah there's no way we could
survive on a gas giant we'd need much
more information before we send humans
to any possible Earth
2.0's so right now NASA is developing a
tiny probe to travel at 1th of the speed
of light it could greatly expand our
knowledge of
exoplanets and we shouldn't limit
ourselves to looking just at
exoplanets a moon receives direct solar
energy from its star and the planet at
orbits reflects solar energy toward it
so maybe a moon could be more suitable
for human life than an exoplanet the
most earthlike planet in our solar
system is Titan Saturn's largest moon so
if we want to save thousands of years of
traveling maybe Titan could make a good
second home for
[Music]
us
635 light years from where you are
sitting way out there in outer space
lies a planet the first planet to be
discovered within the habitable zone of
a sunlike
star its name is Kepler
22b when a planet is located within a
star's habitable zone it means there is
a chance that liquid water exists on its
surface and where there's water there's
also the possibility of life human
life how long would it take to get to
Kepler 22b
what would the weather be like over
there and why would you need to get
jacked before arriving on this new
planet this is what if and here's what
would happen if you live on Kepler
22b Kepler 22b is what scientists call
an exoplanet it's a planet outside our
solar system spotting an exoplanet like
Kepler 20 to be is often not easy the
bright glare of the Stars they orbit
tends to keep them hidden from our
telescopes what did scientists come up
with to get around
in looking at the stars themselves to
see if they can find anything unusual
about them they spotted Kepler 22b using
What's called the transit method they
watched Kepler 22 the star this
exoplanet orbits around and know noticed
that its brightness changes over time
that was because Kepler 22b was blocking
the Stars light with this scientists
were able to learn both the size of 22b
and how it orbits and it looks like this
distant Space Rock could become our next
home okay but what do we really know
about Kepler
22b its mass is 36 times that of Earth
with a radius of 2 and 1/2 times larger
than ours one year on Kepler 22b is 290
days it's also located 15% closer to its
star than we are to the
sun if Earth scooched over that close to
our star you'd be fried Kepler 22b on
the other hand is lucky to have a son
that is remarkably similar to ours but
also smaller and cooler this close
proximity to its star allows the planet
to receive about the same amount of
sunlight as we get over here the
temperature on Kepler 22b could be about
15 to 22° C similar to Earth's Spring
weather and quite habitable if you ask
me but our galaxy can be a cruel place
and not everything is good news some
models suggest Kepler 22b is rotating on
its side kind of like our very own
Uranus this may sound insignificant but
it adds potentially deadly
complications this would mean that its
North and South poles are shrouded in
either Darkness or sunlight for half a
year and this ain't simply a matter of
whether you're a daytime or a nighttime
person a world like Kepler 22b spinning
on its side means that temperatures
could change from boiling to
freezing which wouldn't be great for
human
life I know what a bummer but don't
despair yet because our galaxy is also
big enough to include some hope new
studies suggest that Kepler 22b might be
covered in an ocean 50 m deep and that
ocean would be able to act as natural
climate control keeping the wild
temperatures at Bay you see an ocean can
store heat in the summer and release it
during the winter which results in a
mild climate like you needed another
reason to live close to the
water but hold on how would you even
make it all the way to Kepler
22b I mean even if you were traveling at
the speed of light it would take you
years your best bet could be to
hibernate through the trip inside a
device that preserves your body way past
its natural lifespan like cryogenic
sleep NASA has already developed a
cryosleep chamber that can lower an
astronaut's body temperature to as low
as 32°
C this would trigger natural
hibernation during which catheters would
provide your body with nutrients and
remove any waste
but even in cryo sleep it would be quite
the long risky trip this leads us to the
most dangerous part about this journey
All That Remains Unknown about Kepler
22b for starters we still don't really
know what gravity is like there it could
be twice as strong as our planets if
that was the case a 10 kg sack of
potatoes would now weigh 20 kg
and your body would also factor into the
mix is your current weight 75 Kg well
good luck suddenly dealing with 150 kg
of you and just for safety settlers such
as yourself would need to bulk up really
bulk up only through intense strength
training would you increase your chances
of being able to walk on Kepler
22b and once you got jacked on Earth
you'd have to figure out ways to
preserve that muscle through all
635 years of light speed
travel but humans aren't the only life
form that would be affected by a
stronger gravity plants brought from
Earth for oxygen and nutrition might not
survive on Kepler 22b when you try
growing them there and if you brought
any animals with you they'd need to step
up the evolution process higher gravity
could lead to creatures developing
additional legs to move around it could
also determine the location and size of
internal
organs but the Mysteries don't end there
scientists still don't know for sure
that Kepler 22b is even a rocky planet
it might be gous similar to Neptune or
it could be entirely covered with water
if you and the other first first
settlers woke up from your cryo sleep
and found yourself on a gas planet yeah
that would be a downer you wouldn't have
a solid surface to even land your ship
not to mention a place to set up camp in
that case you and your crew would need
to figure out how to build a cloud city
orbiting the planet if you landed on an
ocean planet a submarine town would be
in
order discovering Kepler 22 B is a rocky
planet would be hitting the jackpot then
right well not so fast Venus is also
made of rock and yet its dense
atmosphere consisting of greenhouse
gases makes it uninhabitable with
scorching temperatures far too hot for
liquid water if this was also the
situation with Kepler 22b our only
chance at thriving on this exoplanet
would be to employ robots watch that
could build underground shelters the
place where maybe just maybe the
temperature might be cool enough for you
to
Bear it just goes to show you that a
prime location is no guarantee for human
survival and as exciting as it might
seem to find other worlds to inhabit our
own Earth Remains the perfect Habitat
for Humanity but this blue Mar like
planet looks just like Earth but only 5
seconds on this hostile death orb would
kill
you welcome to hd189733b
this planet is enormous even larger than
Jupiter and to keep comparing it to the
largest planet in our solar system it's
also entirely made of gas that's why
scientists classify HD1 89 733b as a hot
Jupiter this planet is located so close
to its star that it completes its orbit
in just over 2
days yeah hd189733b
is 13 times closer to its Sun than
Mercury is to our sun and even though
its star is cooler than ours this fake
Earth is still way outside its star
systems habitable zone that means no
liquid water can exist on a planet's
surface just how this giant gous planet
developed so close to a star is still a
mystery one theory is that hd189733b
formed right next to it during the Stars
earliest moments or it could have
developed further away only to be pulled
in as the rest of the planetary system
formed
but there's one thing we know for sure a
visit to hd189733b
would be a plunge into hell with no
chance of
Escape now even if you knew there wasn't
a single drop of liquid water on this
planet you'd have a hard time believing
it as you approached the giant blue
marble with an average daytime
temperature of nearly 1100° C this
planet is twice as hot as Venus and
Venus is the hottest planet in our solar
system one of the reasons for this
intense heat is that the planet is
tidily locked to its star just like our
own moon is to Earth that means
hd189733b
takes as much time to spin on its axis
as it does to revolve around the star so
one side of the planet is constantly in
daylight while the other side is
shrouded in darkness the inviting look
of this world doesn't come from its
oceans like it does here on Earth no
this hellish Planet gets its color from
clouds of molten silic
particles these particles scatter more
blue light than red making the planet
appear blue silica is the primary
ingredient in glass and you should bring
a heavy duty umbrella because you'd need
to take cover from what would
essentially be hot molten glass
rainstorms but that's not the only
danger you'd need to be ready to brace
yourself against the extremely powerful
winds that you'd find sweeping across
the planet with speeds up to 7,000 km
per hour these gusts are almost 30 times
stronger than even the most powerful
Category 5 hurricanes on earth compared
to the strongest winds on other planets
in our solar system hd's winds are
almost four times stronger than those on
Neptune but hey they might smell a
little better than the ice giants
hydrogen sulfide clouds those carry a
whiff of rotten
eggs hd's winds are so fast that they'd
whip past you at about six times faster
than the speed of sound they would be
extremely loud but I think you'd be more
worried about them tearing your body
apart you might be long gone by now
killed by that molten glass
rain in any case you wouldn't last too
long on hd189733b
I really don't recommend traveling
there but there are some planets out
there that can kill you even
faster check out Ogle
t56b this gas giant sits in a galaxy
nearly 100 light years away from Earth
it's even larger than HD its mass is
nearly 1.4 times as much as Jupiter's
and somehow it's even closer to its star
too you'd find this world to be
incredibly scorching hot surface
temperatures on this planet average
around 1700°
C that's so hot that it turns metal to
gas creating iron clouds in the upper
atmosphere
if you got caught in the rain here you'd
find it to be an extremely unpleasant
and deadly shower of hot molten iron
your skin would burn right off and so
would your
insides but things could get even
hotter some 670 light years away from
Earth there's a planet so hellish that
it's tearing molecules apart meet kelt 9
B this gas giant is almost three times
more massive than Jupiter it takes kelt
only one and a half Earth days to speed
through the orbit around its sun and
just like hd189733b
it's tidy locked with one side always
facing the hot star landing on this
planet you'd experience temperatures as
high as
4300 de C it's the most scorching exop
Planet we've ever discovered scientists
call this gas giant an ultra hot Jupiter
and those high temperatures also make
kelt 9B hotter than most stars in the
universe so hot that it would destroy
you come on this world rips apart
molecular hydrogen gas what do you think
it would do to your body but before you
even arrive on this hot planet you'd be
exposed to deadly amounts of radiation
coming from its host Sun yeah kelt 9B
receives about 44,000 times more energy
from its star than Earth does from the
Sun this radiation would cook you alive
instantly okay if you somehow managed to
survive all the lethal radiation of kelt
star and the unimaginable heat of the
planet well you'd still have to take on
its incredibly strong winds scientists
think those winds could reach speeds of
60 km/
second yeah that's 30 times faster than
the winds on the deceivingly Earth
looking Planet
hd189733b
okay so if I get this straight kelt 9B
would swirl you burn you and tear your
molecules apart hm 1 out of 10 would not
recommend thousands of light years from
Earth there could be another planet
hospitable to life
Kepler
69c and you're about to travel to this
alien world to see that life with your
own
eyes what would it be like to make this
Epic Journey so far across the
universe what kind of planet would you
be likely to find upon
arrival and if you did discover Life
what would it look
like this is what if and here's what
would happen if there's life on Kepler
69c located
20383 light years from Earth in the
signis constellation is a potential
super Earth at least that's what it's
often referred to as Kepler 69c is an
exoplanet about 1.7 times larger than
our planet and it could also be around
three and 1/2 times more
massive but there's a catch we don't
really know if this planet is located
within the habitable zone of its
star if it's too close Kepler 69c would
be too hot for liquid water to exist on
its surface if it's too far from its Sun
well then it would be nothing more than
a frigid
world what we do know is that Kepler 69c
orbits its star about 40% closer than
Earth orbits the Sun and that could mean
that it isn't actually a super Earth it
could be a super
Venus so if you traveled all the way
here would you find life or a thick
scorching atmosphere boiling every drop
of water on the
planet before you begin your journey to
Kepler 69 see there'd be one very
important thing to keep in mind it's far
away almost 600 times further away than
Proxima centuri our closest neighboring
star even if you could travel say 1% of
the speed of light you wouldn't get
there anytime soon at this speed you
could whip around Earth in just over 13
seconds but to get to Kepler 69c well
that would take you about
238,000 years to even make this trip
possible you'd need a super Advanced
hibernation pod you know you don't want
to grow too old and die before you could
even get to your
destination am I right well hibernation
technology that could help you sleep for
over 200,000 years doesn't exist yet but
hey this is what if anything's possible
by the time your ship makes its arrival
any life that may exist on Kepler 69c
today could evolve or Advance into
something entirely different think about
it this way 300,000 years ago humans
were just beginning to create stone
tools and
Spears and look at you now making a trip
across the Galaxy looking back at the
planet you left behind who knows what
changes would happen to our human
civilization during your trip no matter
what it's way too late to turn around
now based on the planet's distance from
its star we know that Kepler 69c
receives a similar amount of sunlight as
Venus and despite being more massive
than Earth it has a relatively low
density all this means is that instead
of metals this rocky planet is made of
silicate and carbonate minerals that
could make things a little complicated
you see with all these minerals in the
crust Kepler 69c could have a really
thick atmosphere and to make matters
worse this atmosphere would be composed
mostly of carbon
dioxide uhoh did you choose the wrong
super earth to travel to yeah if Kepler
69c is anything like Venus it would be a
pretty hot planet all because similar to
Venus its clouds would trap the Heat and
create an extreme greenhouse effect
Kepler 69 C's atmosphere would be caught
in an endless cycle of getting thicker
and
hotter but nobody said this world should
be habitable for you oh no once you took
off your helmet you'd instantly melt and
suffocate
like I said life on this planet would be
completely different from what you'd
imagine as you made your approach you'd
find surface temperatures as high as
475° C and the atmospheric pressure
would be over 90 times that of Earth at
sea level it would be like being 900 M
deep in the ocean except you'd be on dry
land with conditions like this you'd
likely not find anything resembling an
ocean here just like on Venus the high
temperatures would boil away all the
water whatever life you could
potentially encounter on this planet it
would need to be able to survive in
these brutal conditions or it would have
to exist somewhere else besides the
surface one place you could Discover
Life on Kepler 69c would be up in the
clouds around 50 km up temperatures
would be much much cooler they would
range from about 30 to 70° C and with
its low density this planet could have a
surface gravity that would be just over
70% of what's found on Earth this weaker
gravity could allow life forms to thrive
in the sky where Kepler 69c is most
hospitable life could just be floating
freely in the atmosphere
this would be another way in which this
planet could have far more in common
with Venus than with Earth probes around
Venus have picked up traces of a gas
that could be a potential sign of life
phosphine if you discovered phosphine in
Kepler 69 C's atmosphere it could be the
result of bacteria that don't require
oxygen to
survive but be ready to hold your nose
this Melly gas has an odor similar to
decaying fish on earth the bacteria that
produce phosphine often live in swamps
or Wetlands but on Venus or Kepler 69c
this bacteria could exist in the thick
oxygenless atmosphere
itself so in the end you may have
traveled a very very long way to find
the smallest and stinkiest of life forms
now on the upside you've just discovered
extraterrestrial
life this is a planetary emergency
evacuation please remain calm and board
your space
shuttles you know even though Humanity
might not have to leave the Earth in
your lifetime we should start preparing
early
on not only could it take centuries to
set up the relocation program it would
take generations to move to a potential
new
home that right there is Proxima centu b
or just Proxima B it's the closest
potentially habitable planet out there
its temperatures are in the bearable
range and it could have just the right
breathable
atmosphere we only have to get
there how long would our journey last
how many people would we send to
populate the new world
successfully and what if it turned out
that Proxima B wasn't as habitable as we
thought this is what if and here's what
would happen if we relocated Humanity to
Proxima
be when astronomers started finding
planets outside our solar system or
exoplanets we realized that there are
many worlds out there
that meant that Earth doesn't have to be
our home
forever and that we don't have to die
with our planet when the sun engulfs it
some 5 billion years from
[Music]
now now that we found over 4,100
exoplanets we've learned something
rather
disappointing not all exoplanets are
good for humans to live
on most of the worlds we've encountered
are either ice giants like Neptune or
gas giants like Jupiter and Saturn only
10061 of those planets are terrestrial
like
Earth and when it comes to sustaining
human life being terrestrial isn't quite
enough Proxima B is very promising it
orbits a red dwarf star called Proxima
centori in a system with three stars in
it Proxima centu is small it only has
between 7 and 1/2 and 50% of our Sun's
mass that's a good thing because the Red
Dwarf Proxima centori is so much smaller
than our yellow dwarf Sun it burns at a
lower
temperature it takes stars like Proxima
centu much longer to burn through all of
their hydrogen
Supply because of that proximus centor
has a lifetime of trillions of years
while our sun has a 10 billion year
expiration
term that alone makes Proxima b a good
candidate for
relocation that and the fact that its
orbit lies in Proxima Cent's habitable
zone that means there's the potential
for liquid water and comfortable surface
temperatures if we're lucky Proxima B
would have an atmosphere that we could
breathe if it does the surface
temperatures would be in the range of
30° I don't know about you but I'd move
there right now I just need to warn you
that there are a few
problems a trip to Proxima B would be
long and very
dangerous Proxima B might be the closest
habitable exoplanet we've got but that
doesn't mean it's close
the red dwarf star Proxima centu is
about 4.3 light years away that means
that if you could travel at the speed of
light it would take you 4.3 years to get
there nothing we've built so far can
reach that kind of
speed realistically a trip to Proxima
centu in a space shuttle would take
165,000 years give or take
that's right some of the colonists would
be born in
transit some of them would never see the
Earth some of them would never see
Proxima
be they'd just live their lives aboard
the spaceship and die in
space how many humans would we need to
send on a mission
exactly well according to some
calculations 98 people would be just
enough their descendants would arrive at
Proxima B with enough genetic diversity
to populate the entire planet and that's
accounting for possible cases of
infertility inbreeding and sudden
deaths in those calculations the crew
would be traveling on something faster
than a space
shuttle their mission to Proxima B would
only take 6,300
years but don't be surprised technology
is constantly
improving right now a scientific and
technological program called
breakthrough initiatives is looking at
how we can get in the neighborhood of
proximus centuri within one
generation their project starshot is
working on an ultralight unmanned probe
that would reach the star system in just
years now I definitely need to sign up
but again Proxima B is really far away
it's so far that we can't even see see
if it has an
atmosphere it might just happen that we
would arrive at a frozen planet with
surface temperatures of
-40° and even if it has an atmosphere it
might not be the right one we might
still enjoy warm temperatures but we'd
be doing that in space suits with oxygen
tanks or Proxima B could be tidy locked
to Proxima centor meaning that one of
the planet's sides would always face its
star and the other side would be plunged
Into
Darkness space flight itself could bring
some unpleasant
surprises spending an entire lifetime in
a zero gravity environment would lead
the crew members to lose muscle and bone
density they'd be constantly exposed to
space radiation their microbiomes immune
systems and physiology would all be
different from
ours they wouldn't be the same kind of
humans as we are they would change their
values and culture they might forget all
the farming techniques we'd teach them
to sustain themselves in space and on
their new
planet they might change their mind
about the mission altogether and just
turn their spaceship in a different
direction who knows they might even come
back to earth and take revenge for all
those years they were forced to spend in
space
if that happens I'll be asking for a
refund sending anyone on a mission like
this is a huge
risk we'd need to design and build a
vehicle choose the space Travelers very
carefully Supply them with all the food
and water and make sure they could
become self-
sustaining we'd have to design new
propulsion navigation hibernation and
life support systems
and we have no way of knowing if Proxima
B is actually habitable well now I don't
really feel like going there do
you Avatar's Pandora is the wildest most
beautiful and most deadly place in the
Galaxy I mean who wouldn't want to live
here but how could the air kill you what
elements could make your body
glow and how could a gas giant destroy
Pandora's
surface this is what if and here's what
would happen if you lived on
Pandora welcome to
Pandora located in the alpha centor star
system this world is shrouded in mystery
and the Cinematic rules created by James
Cameron for starters Pandora isn't even
a planet it's a moon of a gas giant just
like our Jupiter if this deadly Moon
existed in real life it would have to
follow the laws of physics and that's
good news for you because on Pandora
you'd weigh 20% less than you do on
Earth take advantage of that weaker
gravity and leap across the Untamed
alien jungle but under no circumstances
should you ever jump in this
water the gas giant Pandora revolves
around is called
polyphemus this massive planet is only a
bit smaller than Jupiter but it's big
enough to destroy all life on the world
you just arrived on Pandora and
polyphemus are tidily locked so only one
side of this moon is always facing its
gas J Giant and that's dangerous because
it could cause tidal heating when one
side gets a slightly larger
gravitational pole than the other sure
this could create floating mountains
along the magnetic waves of polyphemos
except Pandora's surface wouldn't be
anything like it is in the movie in
reality it would look more like
Jupiter's moon IO which also happens to
be the most volcanically active world in
the solar system and if that wasn't
enough Pandora's Sky would be
radioactive well sort
of if the magnetosphere of polyphemus
was just as big as Jupiter's Pandora
would be trapped within it there it
would be bombarded with charged
particles from its own star system if
Pandora didn't have its magnetosphere
you'd have no buffer from these intense
Rays so you'd better wear a what if
approved protection suit and trust us
you would want to have this suit because
even if it wasn't radioactive the
atmosphere would still kill you on
Pandora the air would be mostly made up
of carbon dioxide and Xenon both of
these gases in high concentration would
instantly suffocate you oh and that
rotten smell yeah that's hydrogen
sulfide yeah won't kill you but you'll
wish you were dead you might have to
live underground or maybe even
underwater in avatar The Way of the
water you'll dive under the waters of
Pandora but if this planet existed the
water could kill you that's because that
water would likely be highly acidic
thanks to the high carbon dioxide levels
in the
atmosphere it could be so bad it would
dissolve all sea life that has
shells yeah and that would severely
affect the food chain even worse one dip
in these Waters could burn your skin off
you'd need to make sure that protection
suit was
waterproof but if you set up your life
in the ocean well you'd miss the beauty
above the surface since Pandora and its
gas giant are tily locked polyphemus
would always be visible in the sky you
would watch Alpha centor a rise and set
just as our son does but polyphemus
would never leave your sight if you were
on Pandora's right side The Other Side
of the Moon would never get this
magnificent view this comes with some
tradeoffs like you'd have a hard time
falling asleep the alpha centory star
system Pandora is located in has not
just one not two but three sons Pandora
would orbit around Alpha centor a but
another star Alpha centor B would also
be sending a lot of light Pandora's way
it burns
2300 times as bright as the full moon on
Earth and you wouldn't even be able to
watch Netflix during your sleepless
nights standard Electronics wouldn't
last long in this environment not with
all that radiation and electrical
interference you'd need space marine
grade technology to survive in this
world at least there would be enough
animals and plants for you to Feast on
only I'd recommend running chemical
tests for heavy metals and strong acids
before you eat anything undetected
toxins could destroy your kidneys and
liver and there might be an unexpected
side effect if you ate too much glowing
food you might become
bioluminescent Pandora would be a world
of incredible species and extreme
Wildlife hey soon enough you might be
taming an econ for the commute around
your strange and lethal
home 120 light years away from us
there's an exoplanet that can
potentially host
life it's called
k218b and it's a world you'd want to
visit
k218b isn't exactly like Earth it's more
like a super Earth yeah it's 2.6 times
larger and almost nine times more
massive than our
planet scientists think it could be a
hyen exoplanet which is just a fancy way
of saying that it likely has a
hydrogen-rich atmosphere and is covered
in liquid ocean that means that
k218b could be home to alien
life only it would take a really long
time to get there if you were hurdling
toward this space Rock from Earth you'd
reach your destination in about 1.3
million years yeah you heard right
million k218b has a lot of methane and
carbon dioxide in its atmosphere that's
not exactly breathable air so you'd
still need a space suit to walk on this
world and I wouldn't be too hyped up
about its ocean either if an exoplanet
has liquid on it it doesn't mean that
the liquid is water it could be methane
or ammonia even acid like even in our
own own solar system There's a Moon
covered in liquid Lakes but these are
methane and ethane lakes and I wouldn't
recommend swimming
there k218b could have a pretty mild
temperature for an exoplanet that is at
-100° C you'd find this world incredibly
cold now the most exciting thing we
found out about this world is that it
could have traces of dimethyl sulfide
woot woot well on Earth this molecule
can only be produced by living things
and that means
k218b could be home to alien life now it
doesn't mean that this life would be
intelligent it could be aquatic or
microbial maybe even complex life if the
conditions for it are just right we
won't know for sure unless we travel to
explore this Interstellar
world
now how do we know all this well we had
the James web Space Telescope look at
this distant world and take detailed
measurements of its atmosphere most of
the exoplanets have been discovered
using What's called the transit method
it's when a planet passes in front of
its star and blocks its
Starlight that's when scientists study
the wavelengths around the planets and
some of those wavelengths can tell us
what kind of atmosphere those distant
planets
have the problem is exoplanets are
really far away trying to figure out
what their surfaces are like just by
peering through even our most powerful
telescopes is not easy some scientists
will argue that k218b isn't a super
Earth at all but a mini
Neptune and that's a bummer because as
you know Neptune is an ice Giant and if
k218b is also ice giant then the chances
for alien life on this planet don't look
so
good now you don't have a million years
to travel to this world to discover it
for yourself so maybe we should look at
a world that's a lot closer to earth
like Proxima centor
P Proxima centor is the closest star
we've discovered only 4.2 light years
away from Earth it's part of the alpha
centory star system with not two but
three stars orbiting each
other the exoplanet Proxima centor B
orbits only one of these stars but
you'll still see the other two stars as
bright dots in the
sky this exoplanet is slightly larger
than Earth and revolves uncomfortably
close to its host star luckily that star
is a red dwarf and that's much cooler
and smaller than our sun which is good
news because that means this planet
isn't getting toasted like
Mercury scientists estimate Proxima
centor B has an average temperature of
about - 39°
c that's pretty comfortable as far as
alien worlds go the bad news is that we
still don't know much about the
exoplanet's gravity or atmosphere it
might be our best candidate to set up an
Interstellar base but it also could have
a harsh environment unsuitable for
Humanity's future home it might even
have an ocean of acid or something
deadly like
that the only way to find out is to
travel there and if Proxima centory B
doesn't work out well don't worry there
are plenty of potentially habitable
worlds out there like this
one Ross 128b is 11 light years from
Earth it's the second closest
potentially habitable World scientists
have discovered and it's more promising
than Proxima centor B the thing is they
both orbit red dwarf stars only Proxima
B's host star is a lot more active and
violent it occasionally erupts and
bathes Proxima B in
radiation Ross 128 B's star is nice and
quiet and even though this world orbits
20 times closer to its star than Earth
is to the sun it still lies in the
habitable zone because like I said red
dwarfs are way cooler than the Sun and
by Cooler I just mean
temperature this world could have a
balmy average temperature of 23° C
that's only slightly hotter than the
average temperature here on Earth I
don't know about you but I could settle
there now we don't know enough about
this world to call it our new home it
likely has lots of harmful radiation
reaching its surface and its atmosphere
might not be breathable but hey that's
not much worse than Mars with efficient
life support systems in place we could
make it work besides this super Earth
might have its own life on it if Ross
128b did have alien life it could be
extremely different from what you might
imagine just think about making the
first contact with an alien
species what would that be
like I mean it could go very wrong too
for one we might not survive the trip to
any exoplanets even the nearest ones so
far we've discovered and confirmed over
5,000 alien worlds 63 of them are
potentially habitable but we just can't
know for sure
there are hundreds of billions of alien
worlds in the Milky Way
galaxy and scientists have already
discovered and confirmed over 5,000 of
them they call these worlds exop planets
some of them are really small like
Kepler 37b this tiny planet is even
smaller than Mercury the smallest planet
in our solar system Kepler 37 is just
slightly larger than our own Moon it
could easily replace our Cosmic
companion in the night sky only it's
pretty far from us this tiny space rock
is located 28 light years from Earth
where it orbits a star that's a bit
smaller and cooler than our sun small
rocky worlds like Kepler 37b are a
pretty rare find because they're so tiny
they're more difficult to spot but
scientists have still managed to confirm
about 200 of these worlds
most of them are many many times closer
to their Stars than our planet is to the
Sun and Kepler 62c is no exception this
Mars sized exoplanet orbits its star
roughly four times closer than Mercury
orbits our sun it only takes a little
over 12 Earth days to make a full orbit
Kepler 62c must be scorching hot and
extremely volcanic definitely not the
kind of place you'd want to
visit and neither is this exoplanet koi
55b scientists think this planet used to
be the size of Jupiter but then its Sun
exploded into a red giant and swallowed
the planet whole h no surprise there koi
55b is incredibly close to its star so
close that it takes this hellish World
less than 5 hours to make one orbit and
koi 55b is evaporating so much that it
will soon disappear from its planetary
system it's not alone many of these
planets have their atmospheres torn Away
by their host Stars some 41 light years
from Earth there's a super Earth that
used to be a mini
Neptune GJ 1132 B might have had a thick
hydrogen atmosphere in the past but its
young hot star stripped it away leaving
only a rocky core
behind when its star Stripped Away its
original atmosphere some of the gases
were absorbed into the planet's mantle
and now through this planet's volcanism
they're released back GJ 1132 B could
have become a potentially habitable
world but it's 26 times closer to its
star than Mercury is to the sun no
chances for life on this super
Earth but life might be possible on
these slightly larger super Earths
scientists have found many of these
worlds orbiting In Their sunlike Stars
habitable zones and that's good news now
we'd have to go and explore more of
these planets up close to find out what
their atmospheres are like this one
seems intriguing Kepler 452b is 1.6 time
the size of Earth and it's about 6
billion years old Earth is a youngster
compared to this world our planet is
only 4 and 1/2 billion years
old okay now I know this is your
favorite exoplanet Kepler
22b and I like it too this super Earth
might be covered in a super ocean it
sits comfortably in its Stars habitable
zone and has a huge potential for Life
the only problem is that it's big Kepler
22b is 2.4 times larger than Earth and
about nine times more massive if Kepler
22b was the size of Earth it would have
an average surface temperature of about
16° C but because it's a lot bigger than
Earth it could be a rocky planet a water
world or even a gaseous Planet like
Neptune and speaking of gous planets at
this size exoplanets stop being super
Earths and become gas giants more than
half of all exoplanets we've discovered
are either Neptune like ice Giants or
gas giants like
Jupiter many of them orbit a little too
close to their host stars and they pay a
high price for that proximity for one
they're incredibly hot and sometimes
their host star rips their atmosphere
away H kind of like what GJ 1132 B went
through but among them there are some
cold planets too o this is Kepler 16b
it's not quite as large as Jupiter but
the cool thing about it is that it
orbits not one but two stars only you
wouldn't be able to see those stars
because you wouldn't be able to stand on
its surface you see Kepler 16b is a
Saturn sized gas giant it might have
some rocky elements inside it but its
two host stars are much cooler than our
sun making Kepler 16b a frigid lifeless
World okay now on to the worlds that are
bigger than Jupiter this delicious
exoplanet has the density of a
marshmallow toi 3757 B is slightly
larger than Jupiter but it's not nearly
as massive but there are always bigger
and batter planets out there like Kepler
7B this one is interesting Kepler 7B is
larger than Jupiter but it has half of
Jupiter's mass this means the planet is
like a super light Cloud a scorching hot
Superlight Cloud Kepler 7B is a hot
Jupiter planet it's 12 times hotter than
the king of the solar system still
Kepler 7B is not the hottest or the
weirdest of the
exoplanets some of these gas giants are
so unimaginably hot that they tear
molecules apart yeah and some planets
are just doomed 1,400 light years away
from Earth a star slightly bigger and
hotter than our sun is devouring its
Planet this planet is called wasp 12b
it's almost double the size of Jupiter
but it's not going to last very long as
far as planetary lives go wasp 12b is so
close to its star that it takes just
over one Earth day to complete its orbit
it's own star is actually eating the
planet's atmosphere making it stretch
into the shape of this egg 10 million
years from now wasp 12b will be gone and
some exoplanets are unimaginably huge
the biggest one of them is almost seven
times larger than Jupiter hd10 0 546b
isn't just seven times larger than
Jupiter it's also 750 times more massive
HD orbits its star 10 times further away
than Jupiter orbits the sun that's
pretty far and it makes scientists
wonder how this gigantic exoplanet
formed so far away from its star there's
no doubt that some exoplanets out there
look promising for finding life we've
found quite a lot of them orbiting in
the habitable zone of their stars in
fact some of these worlds might even be
better for life than Earth but that's a
story for another what
[Music]
if
could there be an even better planet for
us than
earth scientists are searching for a
super habitable world that wouldn't just
rival Earth but be a place where life
could Thrive even more easily and
they're looking at